es braucht viel fingerspitzengefühl um
die empfindlichen weißen stangen aus der
erde zu stechen
kilometerweit erstrecken sich die folien
geschützten spargelfelder hier im
ostdeutschen belek der spargelhof von
familie jacobs ist im frühling ein
beliebtes ausflugsziel
viele besucher wollen das gemüse gleich
erntefrisch kaufen
auch das gehört zum kult um den spargel
tulpen blühen dann ist auch spargelzeit
und fertig die gegend über als nicht
spargelfeld und den tag
bald ist wieder spargel das wort alleine
spargel so geht ein auf der zunge
vanille gefechts kann man sagen
deutschland ich weiß das ja und dann
würde sie sind sehr froh hier zu sein
und dann spargel zuerst sind und
genießen die deutschen sind spargel
europameister beim anbau und auch beim
verzehr liegen sie weit formen pro
saison ist jeder deutsche
durchschnittlich 1,5 kilogramm des
edelgases jahren ist auch ein neues spar
wirtschaftswunder entstanden und wir
haben heute eine pro kopf produktion und
auch eine einem pro-kopf-konsum wie wir
ihnen noch nie hatten für mich ist spa
deshalb kulturgut weil es wie gesagt
nicht gerade eine neue eine
modeerscheinung ist das jetzt gerade mal
spargel gegessen wird sondern das
natürlich schon seit dem mittelalter in
den klostergärten an den königshäusern
spargel verzehrt wurde
in der region von beelitz wird seit 1861
spargel angebaut zehn prozent grüner
spargel der oberhalb der erde wächst und
90% weißer der unter der erde gedeiht
sobald er mit licht in kontakt kommt
verfärbt sich spargel das gemüse der
könige musste immer schon weiß sein und
kerzengerade der spargel würde auch um
eine leichte krümmung haben aber wir
suchen natürlich schon flächen aus das
sind hier sandige flächen das sieht man
auch wenn man den boden wahrnimmt
das rasant und in diesem land in diesem
land wächst der spargel möglichst gerade
und er hat keinen widerstand und weil er
auch ein leichtes der boden erwärmt sich
gut und dadurch kriegt der sparer auch
hier sein einzigartiges aroma mit dem
messer an dem strache runter sticht den
abo den raus er ist leichter zu ernten
wird sein kopf schon aus der erde guckt
spezielle planen schützen ihn vor licht
und natürlich kommt das gemüse auf dem
spargelhof in vielen variationen auf den
tisch bodenständig mit schnitzel im crap
teig als auflauf oder klassisch mit
kartoffeln und sauce hollandaise wie man
aus fein geschälten spargel und krisen
macht zeigt michael kempf
der chefkoch aus dem berliner zwei
sterne restaurant facil vermischt mit
himbeeren und paprika ich möchte den
spargel haben und er bekommt ein
komplettes gericht umstellt und die
beilagen garnituren und saucen durch den
spargel nicht übertönen
der spargel ist dann der könig auf den
teller
am liebsten brad der spargel in der
pfanne kocht dann mit preisen von salz
und braunem zucker zusammen mit
zitronenscheiben und etwas butter so
kurz wie möglich
bei manchen gerichten im restaurant
facil werden aber auch weißer und grüner
spargel kombiniert wie zum beispiel bei
diesem spargelsalat ich finde sehr
elegant zurückhaltend und der grüne ist
er brachial sehr mutig doch wie ist es
um die zukunft des weißen spargels
bestellt
lohnkosten machen wir uns über 50
prozent der gesamtkosten aus und wenn
die jetzt überproportional steigen kann
es passieren dass der spargel wieder
deutlich elitärer wird so wie es im 17
18 jahrhundert war vitaminreich
kalorienarm und mit einem ganz eigenen
feinen geschmack der weiße spargel ist
zumindest noch das frühlingsgemüse
nummer eins in deutschland
[Musik]